and there's number 48 getting set to go
herman
looking for his third victory of the
year middle school era of 2.25
this is in the air to charlie and he'll
make the catch
go out there again and the pitch ends up
on the inner part but
when you throw 98
you're going to get that kind of result
for the knot and both fly balls to right
field have been fastballs that have
jammed the astros hitters
and correa lines this ball towards top
he's got it and that's a quick
and efficient inning see the numbers on
javier four starts this season a 2.91
era
last time out did a very good job in a
bounce-back outing after pitching poorly
in
oakland there goes the runner on the 3-2
pitch sent in the air
into right field shading his eyes from
the sun is
josh redick and he puts it away for the
first down 1-7
straight a major league best winning
streak currently swinging a miss got him
on the breaking ball down
low darn close every single year no
matter how you start
swinging a miss javier gets aronado to
end the inning
2-2 sway and a miss got him that time
with a knuckle curve first strikeout of
the afternoon
for marcus that will bring up kyle
tucker paul
smoked in the right center field he
might have another triple this ball
going all the way to the wall
cut off at the wall by hilliard in the
score is reddick
tucker is going to get the third another
triple
tucker three triples in the last two
games my goodness
now martine maldonado comes to the plate
maldonado rips one over the head of
orinado another base hit for martin with
a runner
scoring kyle tucker makes it a
two-nothing game as he crosses the plate
on maldonado's 17th rbi of the year
now george will bat with first and
second and two outs
that ball is hit hard that's into left
field to third base
and being held and now being sent home
is taylor jones the ball gets by tapia
into second base goes springer over to
third goes maldonado
astros now lead three to nothing the
astros scoring three times here
a chance for more with jose altuve
standing in
altuve sends one into left center field
pretty well hit this ball's carrying and
off the wall
two runs will score altuve into second
base
two rbi doublets now five to nothing a
3-0 pitch
that altuve drives almost out of the
park lead off
single for the second straight inning
ryan mcmahon the hitter here
pitch hit pretty well to center field
going back springer to the warning track
to the wall
it's gone touch him
all time for ryan mcmahon to
center field rockies get two runs back
it's
5-2 houston rocky's down
three nolan trying to get goings arenado
swings and drives one to left field
tucker moving back looks up
it is over and out of here
nolan arenado on a line
with his seventh home run of the year
rocky's back within five to three
two on one out for guriel who's over two
gilly shoots one to the right side
that's a base hit that will score altuve
heading to third correa yilly guriel
continues to hit well against the
rockies it's now 6-3 astros guerrielle
with rbi number 11 on the year
tucker goes the other way and that ball
is gonna fall in for a hit
kyle tucker using the whole field carlos
correa scores seven to three
tucker's second rbi of the game well it
feels like the
the knockout punch just kind of lurking
right now and toro drives this one deep
to right center field
it sends back hilliard still going back
looking up see you later
into the astros bullpen that's a
three-run home run for abraham toro
and the astros have opened up a 10-3
lead
ryan mcmahon with a two-run homer in the
second inning
he drives this breaking ball to deep
right center field he's got a
two-homer day touch of all time
for ryan mcmahon
[Applause]
it's 10-5 astros
nobody out second and third and here's
blackman
and this ball is going to drop into
right center field story got a pretty
good read he comes around third
he's coming home two-run single charlie
blackman here come the rockies
10-7 so the rockies will get the tying
run up here at the eighth
on the ground with the slider gloved
there by toro and his throw in time
astros pitchers dodge another bullet
stranding a couple
rockies again get the lead off man
aboard
1-2 ground ball towards third that will
score hilliard the throw to first in
time
to get kemp rbi for kemp 10-8
houston
into right field reddick on the move
diving catch for the win
josh reddick flies through the air
and ryan presley says thank you very
much
the houston astros win their eighth in a
row defeating the colorado rockies by a
final of 10
to 8.